الحقيقه يعني تم الغاء حاله الاداره الجوي
في العاصمه الان قبل دقائق هذه حاله
الانذار تم الاعلان عنها في الساعه
الثامنه صباحا مع نجوم واسع من قبل
الاتحاد الروسي بصواريخ بكروز وايضا اس
300 وطائرات شاهد في جميع انحاء اوكرانيا
كان نصيب العاصمه 14
قذيفه صاروخيه تم اسقاط عدد منها هنالك
ثلاثه مواقع همم يعني اصيب بهذه القبائل
في العاصمه في الضفه اليسرى في منطقه دار
مسكي هنالك مبنيه سكنيين
بشكل كبير والاخر الجزئيه كان هناك همم
ثلاثه اشخاص في هذا في احد المباني
حتى الان لم يتم الاعلان عن اي وفيات في
العاصمه اكيد الهجوم كان على العاصمه وعلى
مدينه خانكم ايضا التي تمت معها صواريخ
300 نحو هذه المدينه القريبه من الحدود
روسيه كذلك لايف تم اطلاق عدد من الطائرات
المسيره شاهد نحو مدينه نيجا لايف كذلك
اوديسا وسومي وجليبرا بترافس والفوف وجيت
كل هذه المدن ثم
الاستضافه اكد عمده الفيف ان هناك همم
اصابات في مدينه الجيب وان هنالك انفجارات
وقعت بالفعل في المدينه في احد المباني
السكنيه ولكن معظم هذه الصواريخ تم
اسقاطها من قبل الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني
عدد الصواريخ كانت 120 صاروخا بحسب افاده
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني مازلنا ننتظر
المعلومات حول ما اذا كان هنالك مزيد من
الاتصالات في المدن الاخرى او حتى في
العاصمه المباني التي تضررت الانقاذ
يعملون على الرفع الانقاذ تاكد من عدم
وجود مصابين تحت الالقاب في هذه المواقع
تم اطلاق الصواريخ طبعا من البحر الاسود
والبحر ومن شبه جزيره القرم هذا الاستهداف
الواسع طبعا استهدف ايضا منشات للطاقه
هنالك بعض المباني ايضا الحكوميه الاداريه
التابعه لاحد محمد مصطفى ايضا دمر بشكل
كبير هذه حصيله الجمله
التي استهدافات التي حدثت اليوم منذ
الثامنه صباح